Good evening, everybody.
I hope you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, though I hope it has been happy.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhodasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhodasa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambuddhasa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one.
So we've trudged our way through the taints, the disgusting oozings, and then we looked at
society and uh each of us came to conclusion whether we're heading towards doom or whether we're at the great turning point so i thought uh we'd move on to um the psychology of the buddha uh around dependence origination so uh remember after he was fully liberated
on that uh that night he then spent seven days according to the uh tradition he spent seven days in bliss really just enjoying the uh ecstasy of being liberated from all suffering those of you who know adjan mahabua
very famous monk in Thailand who declared himself to be fully liberated.
You can see him on YouTube talking about that moment.
And he begins to cry, just the joy of that liberation.
Of course, everybody then said, how could it be an adat if he's crying?
And he gave a rather strong riposte to that.
So after that blissful seven days, he then spent the first part of the night, I think it was a night, going through what became known as dependent origination.
In other words, the whole process whereby we create suffering for ourselves.
And then on the second quarter or whatever, he went the other way, understanding how we can bring it to an end.
And then finally, he made sure he got it right by going both ways up and down.
And remember that the Buddha's technique is always to deconstruct everything.
But having deconstructed our experience, then he shows how it comes together, how it actually works to give us the impression of an entity, of a one being, of a me, of a self, of a soul, call it what you wish.
Just like a good mechanic can pull a car apart and then an engine apart and then put it together again.
Actually, when I was thinking about this, it reminded me of an occasion in my childhood
I had a cousin who was extremely good at engineering and especially doing things like that.
And seemingly as a child, 10, 11 or something, he pulled this watch apart and put it all together again.
Well, I wasn't going to be outdone with that.
I found myself in the kitchen and I took the clock off the cooker and very cleverly took it apart.
But for the life of me, I couldn't get it quite back together again.
However, I didn't really understand why my mother was so angry, because it had lost its alarm.
Anyway, that's the way it was.
So what I'm going to start with is the Salayatana Vibhanga, or the exposition of the sixfold base.
Now, Bhikkhu Bodhi has translated this as the sixfold base.
Ayatana is a sphere.
It's a dimension.
And so one of the qualities of our six senses is that they don't mix into each other.
You can't for the life of you smell through your ears and you can't see through your nose.
uh and they are separate experiences of life so we have vision we have hearing these are two very different uh qualities very different uh capabilities and they don't mix you see uh now remember that in buddhist psychology consciousnesses are arising at a rapid rate depending on where the attention moves or what's calling the attention
so even now as i'm looking at this little gadget and hopefully you can see me looking at you rather than away from you i'm also hearing what i'm saying and thinking what i'm saying all this comes together as as one person looking seeing thinking but in buddhist psychology the millions you know thousands of little consciousnesses that run so rapidly together to give us the impression of continuity
And that, of course, gives us also an impression of solidity.
So what is continuous is, you know, has the feel of always being here in a total congealed way.
And that's basically our delusion.
So just before we go into it, remember that when you read the discourses,
there's only two things that the Buddha really is interested in, and that's ethics and transcendence.
The transcendence he points to, I think he has 250 ways of pointing to Nibbana.
None of them actually hit the nail on the head, because the definition is beyond the psychophysical world, and therefore is indescribable.
And somehow we make a mistake.
So once we understand that this nirvanic element is actually this very awareness, this Buddha, the one who knows within us, then we understand that something's gone wrong with its relationship to this psychophysical organism.
Now, at what point does it actually associate with or identify with this organism?
It's at the point of consciousness.
And at that point of consciousness, what we discover as meditators, when we come back out of the involvement with
the the um with the senses with the emotions with the thought is that we discover ourselves and it is a discovery of being the observer the the the unattached observer the equanimous observer the equanimous feeler the one who knows the one who's experiencing and yet that sense of self that comes with it is a mirror image on that very same uh consciousness
And so there's your first relationship.
And it's through that relationship that you enter into the world of the mind.
So he's very keen on getting us to, first of all, understand from a backwards point of view, starting at the base, how we build up the world.
Okay.
And this is what this sixfold base discourse is trying to do.
So I shall read the passage.
Thus have I heard on one occasion, the Blessed One was living at Saberty and Jetter's Grove and Artipindica's Park.
So we've come across this monastery before.
It was definitely, I think, his favorite.
And there he addressed the bhikkhus thus, Bhikkhus, Venerable Sir, they replied.
And the Blessed One said, Bhikkhus, I shall teach you an exposition of the sixfold base or the sixfold senses.
Listen and attend closely to what I shall say.
Yes, Venerable Sir, the vehicle's replied and the Blessed One said this.
The six internal bases should be understood.
The six external bases should be understood.
The six classes of consciousness should be understood.
The six classes of contact should be understood.
The 18 kinds of mental exploration should be understood.
The 36 position of beings should be understood.
Therein, by depending on this, abandon that.
There are three foundations of mindfulness that the noble one cultivates, cultivating which the noble one is a teacher fit to instruct a group.
Among the teachers of training, it is he that is called the incomparable leader of persons to be tamed.
This is the summary of the exposition of the sixfold base.
Now, I think anybody reading that paragraph for the first time would probably suffer from a severe headache.
It's just there's so much presumption of knowledge in it that it really is a bit of a pain.
So anyway, he now actually gives us an explanation.
The six internal bases should be understood.
So it was said, and with reference to what was this said?
there are the eye base, the ear base, the nose base, the tongue base, the body base, and the mind base.
So it was with reference to this that it is said the six internal bases should be understood.
In other words, the six senses.
Now, we're quite aware of the senses of the retina, for the eye, etc., etc.
Now, it's not as though
uh the retina is of course the uh energy you can call it whatever it is and it is that which leaves the body upon death now you don't have to believe that to understand this but you have to understand that the mind is of a more subtle form than the material body okay so um
At that point, the retina is, shall we say, the sensitive part.
That's the internal sense base.
But that's not what we actually know.
What we actually experience is vision.
It's the capability of seeing.
So that's what he's talking about there.
He's talking about the point where the mind
touches the body and perceives um form light well we'll come to that in a minute so it's the same with the ear the um the sensitive part whatever it's called the drum or something uh all that is actually sensitive to are the incoming waves of pressure um from the air around that's all we're going to that a bit more uh deeply in a bit
so here is saying there are six of these internal bases now when it comes to the mind there's nothing in the scriptures which tells you what the actual physical base of the mind is and i was happy to read that even in the abidama the later teaching there was no base for the mind actually explained but the commentaries
uh felt that there was something missing here so they came to the conclusion that there was a file of blood in the heart the hadaya vatu the base of the heart where the mind actually had its contact with the whole body and um yes um it's it's been difficult to find this little file of blood and there was once an occasion when um
Sayadaw Pandita, who is in America, this is a story I heard, where they asked him, well, what happens in a transplant?
So the heart's taken out and the blood is put through a machine.
So where is this hadaya vata?
Where is this base of the mind?
So he had to say, well, he's in the machine.
So going back to the scriptures, the Buddha doesn't say that it has a base as such.
uh and i personally i just i just presume that it's the whole body in the way but it doesn't have to be because the information coming from the five senses uh is enough for the mind to work out what's actually happening uh around it what's actually coming into the mind from the outside so the next one is the sixth external basis should be understood
so it was said with reference to what was they said there are form base sound base odor base flavor base tangible base mind object base so it was with reference to this that it was said the six external bases should be understood so um
For the eye to see something, there has to be something to be seen.
And what is said to be seen on the actual eye base is just color, which creates a certain sense of form.
But everything else is actually done by the mind.
So at the ear, for instance, what is actually felt at the ear drum is only pressure.
There is no sound.
And it's taken into the mind, through the mind door, and it's there that it's understood as a sound.
And from a sound, a meaning is given to it.
And from a meaning, there's a reaction.
So when you hear the bell of an alarm, the only thing that actually strikes the ear is the pressure waves.
And then everything else comes in.
So first of all, there's a sound and then, you know, it's a bell and you know, it's alarm bell, and then, you know, you've got to get up.
So you come out always at the end of that process.
That's experiential by the way.
Yes.
So, and then on the third one, he says the six classes of consciousness should be understood.
And with reference to what was this said, there are eye consciousness, ear consciousness, nose consciousness, tongue consciousness, body consciousness and mind consciousness.
So it was with reference to this that it was said the six classes of consciousness should be understood.
So you have three components here for us to have an experience.
The first, you have to have that sense base.
You have to have some sort of object and you have to have consciousness.
So you can see if the sound waves come in.
So there's your object.
All right.
The bell.
The ear is what actually brings it into the mind and it must manifest somewhere.
The mind is doing all the work in terms of giving you the reason etc etc and it manifests somewhere.
So this consciousness is just a screen upon which things happen, upon which things are known.
And the delusion is to give that screen of consciousness the intelligence which actually belongs to the awareness, the intuitive awareness, the Buddha.
Got it?
And this is, for those of you who know dependent origination, this is the moment of contact.
So you've got the body and mind.
There's your first split.
There's your first separation.
And then dependent on the body and mind, you've got these six sense bases.
And depending on the six sense base, you have contact.
And at contact, you have to have the sense base, the object, and that screen of consciousness for it to manifest on.
So that hopefully clears up the first bit of that awful paragraph.
The six external bases should be understood, the six internal bases should be understood, the six external bases should be understood, and the six classes of consciousness should be understood, and the six classes of contact should be understood.
So the six classes of contact should be understood.
So it is said, with reference to what is that said, there is eye contact, ear contact, nose contact, tongue contact, body contact and mind contact.
So it is with reference to this that it was said the six classes of contact should be understood.
So that's got us through the first section.
Let's see what the time is.
Yes, I might just do the next bit before we go on to...
Yes.
So then we talk about the 18 kinds of mental exploration, right?
The 18 kinds of mental exploration.
So it was said, and with reference to what was they said?
On seeing a form with the eye, one explores a form productive of joy.
One explores a form productive of grief.
One explores a form productive of equanimity.
On hearing a sound, on smelling an odor with the nose, on tasting a flavor with the tongue, on touching a tangible with the body, on cognizing a mind object with the mind.
Remember, your mind objects are not only this stuff coming in, but your emotions and your thought life, your imaginative life.
All that must appear upon the mind base, the mind consciousness.
one explores the mind object productive of joy one explores the mind object productive of grief and one explores the mind object productive of equanimity thus there are six kinds of exploration with joy six of exploration with grief and six kinds of exploration with equanimity so it was with reference to this that it was said the 18 kinds of mental exploration should be understood so
So we've slightly moved off the sense base here to an internal reaction.
And that reaction is learnt by us.
So even as little babies, we know what is painful and what is not painful.
What makes us happy and what doesn't?
We're very quick to cry when we get upset, when we're not getting enough milk, and we're very quick to smile, at least after a couple of weeks or something, when we feel happy.
And other times, we're very peaceful.
That's if you're a good baby.
So here there's a point where we have this reaction.
And although we use the words joy and grief, of course, it refers back to pleasant and unpleasant.
And this takes us to the next step in the independence origination, which is vedana.
So vedana is an understanding of what we're experiencing as either pleasant or unpleasant.
I said reaction, that's not quite the right word.
It's an interpretation of what we're experiencing from an affective point of view.
In other words, how we feel about it.
So this is about... About...
recognizing that whenever we hear something see something eat something etc etc it's always going to produce a mental state a mental state which is either you know in some level of joy even if it's only a little uh some level of grief if you're only a little and sometimes just an equanimous level which is normally experienced when we have something neutral when there's just a neutral feeling
so for instance even now if you you know your tongue uh because there's no specific specific taste on that it's not producing any particular emotional reaction we don't have a feel about it it doesn't feel either unpleasant or pleasant so that's what the meaning is here so i think that's enough for one night what do you think so i think we'll we shall come back to this exposition um
and hopefully by the end of it we'll know something about the six sense bases in the way that the Buddha wanted us to understand them.
So we can now cool ourselves with a bit of meditation.